do you ever wonder why we don't get a
grand theft auto game every year or why
it's taking so long for a red dead
redemption sequel take-two interactive
has explained why it doesn't release its
non sports titles annually saying it's
weary a product fatigue that can result
from milking of property during a
business presentation held in New York
on Tuesday company president Carl slat
off was asked about the business reasons
behind not annualizing its most popular
brands specifically if that was a
challenge in terms of keeping investors
interested in franchises that go quiet
yes it is a challenge he replied
according to slide off the publishers
reasoning is to avoid franchise fatigue
by managing releases more strictly this
makes a brand viable for longer than one
that's released yearly it's tempting to
have continuous releases and milka
franchise as far as you can we've seen
that fatigue and other franchises in the
games industry with almost every single
franchise for us the latest release is
bigger than the one before take-two's
chief executive Strauss Zelnick echoed
similar sentiments in November 2015 when
he said annual ization can lead to the
erosion in the value of a brand at the
time Zelnick indicated that some of
take-two's franchises would be released
on a more regular rotation though not
necessarily on a yearly schedule he
noted that bioshock and porter lands
franchises are already on this path
titles from its rockstar games division
such as grand theft auto red dead
redemption and Max Payne however are
unlikely to have a set schedule would
you rather see franchises like GTA
released on a yearly basis or with some
sort of schedule let us know in the
comments below and for more news we are
already in the right place
you